foreign
we have this image which you can see if
you're watching the video version on the
screen this one is from Sheila malabam
you want to read what she wrote in she
wrote I want to let go of my shot glass
collection I don't even do shots anymore
most of these were gifted and doubt
anyone would find Value in these
shot shot shots yeah isn't that funny
like
it makes sense that uh people would get
her shot glasses as gifts because if I
went to Sheila's home and saw this shot
glass collection
I would be like Oh Sheila really likes
shot glasses I am going to next time I
see a shot glass I'm going to pick it up
for so
um yeah I could see where yeah you
probably more than half of those were
gifts because you were displaying shot
glasses and people want to make you
happy and add value to your life and
they thought that shot glasses would add
value to your life that's why I always
used to get socks for Ryan because every
time I went to his bedroom there were
just socks all over the floor and so I
was like he must be a sock collector
exactly yes ma'am I love socks that's
great why don't you bring up such a
great point is you the the life that you
display
others will assume that is what brings
you great joy yeah contentment
it amplifies your freedom in some way
but what you're telling me is no this is
just getting in the way I don't even use
these and I don't find them to be
particularly beautiful if you did if
you're like oh this is my art this is my
art case I've been collecting these and
I really get great driver time I walk
past it wow then I'd say amass it but
I'm not going to tell you to trash it
I'm going to tell you too
Smash It
and by Smash It he means donate how fun
would it be to just take a baseball bat
to the whole case film it for tick tock
and you'll go viral so this is gonna be
the uh now it's the amasset trash it or
smash it
segment oh man yeah I mean clearly if
they're not adding value yeah there's no
reason to hang on to it
um you could totally donate that there's
someone out there I'm sure who would
love to display these shot glasses but
yeah if you're not finding Beauty in it
it's not augmenting your life in a
positive way if it's causing more stress
than it is uh happiness or contentment
or whatever it is if it's causing you
more negative feelings then uh yeah I
would go ahead smash it
that's our vote did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free